name three famous English people in the
time it takes to send the ceiling name
or cut support out my tie sex on the
beach
the time it takes this dog to abandon
its stick name for things you'd find in
the kitchen a kettle a toaster a mug and
step name four things we find in a
bedroom lingerie in the time it takes
this dog to fall off the edge nine three
modes of transport without wheels was
that me have a tooth for every doesn't
it
arrow pain in the time it takes this hug
to wake up
name three expat winners Little Mix in
the time it takes this dog to break the
spaghetti twice name three European
countries France Switzerland in the time
it takes this riots break his twig name
for schools paid about gold in the time
it takes this cat to make a leap of
faith name three famous English people
drop a stick name for clothing brands
Urban Outfitters Topshop dsquared in the
time it takes this dog to lick off the
yogurt name three and always that have
less than four legs
[Applause]
kangaroo oh thanks no that arms in the
time it fixes cap to shake off the tape
name five delicious foods nachos sundaes
tree no mayo
just potato and in the time it takes
this cat to give up name for websites
Facebook Instagram Twitter shot in the
time it takes us walls to escape name
four green vegetables broccoli spinach
Brussels sprouts asparagus in the time
it takes this dog to get in the pool
name five weather types
sunny rainy cloudy stormy
[Applause]
[Music]